action Texas Senator Ted Cruz Senator
thank you
Senator Alan dershowitz once said to me
you were one of the best students he's
ever had in the history of teaching
Harvard Law
put your law hat on tell us legally what
you see here
legally I see every single day the
evidence is growing and growing and
growing and we're also seeing you just
played a minute ago Jake Tapper and
Elizabeth Warren neither the corporate
media nor any Congressional Democrat
cares at all
whether the president of the United
States received millions of dollars of
bribes from foreign Nationals even that
little exchange there where Jake Tapper
asked well gosh you know it was sort of
influence peddling and isn't that
bothersome no those are not the
allegations Jake you're a journalist or
you're supposed to be the allegations
are bribery that it wasn't just Hunter
selling access it was Hunter selling
official favors from his father Joe
Biden let's go to what that fd-1023
specifically says the FBI form a
confidential human source that had been
reliable previously to the FBI came
forward and said that the the oligarch
who owns barisma paid five million
dollars to Hunter Biden and five million
dollars to Joe Biden in exchange for Joe
Biden's help getting rid of the
prosecutor that was investigating
Barista and investigating that oligarch
now what is bribery the essence of a
bribery is a quid pro quo we remember
from the the first Trump impeachment the
media Jake knows what a quid pro quo is
he talked about it incessantly when it
concerned Donald Trump quid pro quo is
Latin for this for that bribery is
paying someone something of value in an
exchange for an official favor now the
quo we know happened because as you
noted Joe Biden has confessed to it in a
video interview where he said he went to
Ukraine he held hostage a billion
dollars in U.S loan guarantees and
demanded of the Ukrainian government
fire the prosecutor that is
investigating Barista and investigating
the oligarch we know the quote happened
the only question was did the quid
happen did they pay 10 million dollars
for him to do so if so Joe Biden is
guilty of bribery Hunter is guilty of
selling bribes selling official favors
from his father and if that is the case
Joe Biden should be impeached he should
be removed from office he should be
prosecuted and he should go to prison
and he should share a cell with Hunter
for corrupting the government of the
United States Senator
I agree with Kevin Brock this now
justifies a full investigation into
money laundering and bribery it does but
I sadly say this and I mean sadly I do
not believe in this moment of history
that we currently have equal justice and
equal application of our laws and I
don't see this Department of Justice
ever doing their job they are obsessed
with one man 24 7 365 year in year out
and that's Donald Trump and they will
not they are steadfastly refusing to do
the proper investigation into what I
believe could be the biggest bribery
corruption scandal in the history of
this country from the White House
look there's never been an allegation in
the history of our country like this
that a president of the United States or
a Vice President Joe Biden's case when
he when these allegations occurred sold
official uh uh favors for millions of
dollars the house oversight committee
James Comer just released they have bank
records now that show more than 20
million dollars went to Joe Biden's
family these are payments these are
payments to his brother payments to his
son payments to the Widow of his other
son payments to his grandkids payments
to just about everyone damn near fluffy
the dog got paid by ukrainians and
Russians and kha'zix and and Chinese
Communists and they're paid through
shell corporations now what's a shell
Corporation a shell Corporation is a
legal Fiction it's not a real company
it's not like you start a car wash
business that has employees that
actually does something now a shell
Corporation exists on paper and its main
purpose is to launder money to hide the
money that's coming in I have to tell
you I do not know any individual and
government Republican or Democrat who
has ever done anything remotely like
what is alleged here which has had a
business of selling official favors for
tens of millions of dollars and by the
way they're not getting money Hunter
wasn't getting money from from the
French or the British or the Canadians
or friends of America they were seeking
out Chinese Communists and corrupt
oligarchs who were willing to do things
Sean look
you live a good life have you ever had a
corrupt foreign oligarch transfer
transfer you why are you over a hundred
thousand dollars the exact price for a
brand new fancy sports car Senator uh if
that's a real question uh unfortunately
I just never happened to me I'm
wondering why but I prefer rather than
the Porsche I want the Corvette Z06
um I like to buy America good choice
Senator I got to tell you you still have
it you're on your A game Professor
dershowitz is right thank you for being
with us hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else